ray it's great to be with you today
i want to dive right in how in the world
did the founder of a hedge fund get into
personality assessment
well uh you know i had a lot of people
and
and they all behave differently they all
have strengths and weaknesses and um
so i had the top 150
uh managers uh start with
taking a myers-briggs test which
somebody told me about and
again then i got their results and i
read the results
and i could not believe in many cases
that people actually thought that way
and what happened as we went through
this we guessed them a survey
how accurate was this in describing how
they think
and 85 on a scale of one to five
described it as a four or five
and then that got me gave me insights
and i started to see then through that
process
um that there was an understanding there
was an evolution in the way we were
thinking
we the understanding i'm referring to is
uh
you know sometimes we would drive each
other crazy we'd be
you know like the big picture thinker
dealing with the person
pays a lot of attention to details you
know the big picture thinker would say
why do you have so many all those
details can you can't you just see the
big picture
and the uh detail person would say your
head's in the clouds
if you don't take care of that and the
truth is they're both right
and once we started to realize that and
how they
could work together to do what eat
you know compensate for one's weaknesses
by having the other strengths and
realizing that all these different ways
of thinking were valuable that gave us
better results
so one thing built on each other and i
realized it was
like the most important thing for
individuals development and building
teams
so it sounds like it was helpful for
self-awareness and also for other
awareness
yeah and to have a clarity
of how people think yes
so what happened then you're starting to
give people these assessments you're
getting a sense of
what you're like what they're like it
became a huge part of the way that you
ran bridgewater
right well then you know it's it's
fantastic also because it becomes
data so it becomes evidence-based we
accumulated a lot of data then we
invented other tools like the dot
collector which maybe we'll get into
but when you start to find out in an
objective way
what you're like it allows
just not only the building of teams
because you know you start to say i'd
want one of those think about a team
it's just like a team if you were
a team to take a mountain who's the fast
runner who's the strong guy who could
carry this who's the clever strategist
what roles do you play based on those
abilities so it
was there was that there was better
understanding and appreciation
they would say oh you're one of those ah
i
see and so on and it became
evidence-based so that people could have
their personal development
when we put it together with the dot
collector which is a a tool
getting um that provides what
everybody's thinking pretty much about
everybody
um it then gave great clarity and
i think that what happens in life is by
and large
we have a nature we have our own nature
and we want to pursue in that path
the path toward finding out what's our
fit
and by knowing ourselves and then
knowing how the fits work the fits not
only in terms of the job
but the fits in the relationship that
was extremely powerful
well i was i was excited about this when
we were first introduced
i think six years ago because as an
organizational psychologist i've spent a
lot of my career doing personality
assessment
and it caught me off guard when you said
you know what the old assessments aren't
giving me everything i need
let's build a new one what led you to
that place
well you know we were looking
no one of them did give me all the what
i needed so it got to the point where i
had like six of them i won't rattle off
what the six were
and so i wanted to have one assessment
that was also going to be able to bring
it together and
um just give the total picture of the
person
and that's why that's when i contacted
you and i contacted brian little and i
contacted
john golden you know three great
psychometricians
and and then we began the project to
produce which
what we're so excited to be able to give
for free
to everybody who cares to have it
yeah let's talk more about principles
you so free comprehensive assessment to
give you a sense of what you're like and
what the people around you are like
you've had some interesting people go
through this assessment talk to me a bit
about that
well you know way back when um when i'm
thinking about how do
i replace myself and what what's the
type of person i decided that i wanted
to
identify what i called a shaper the the
what is the magic that the person who
uh visualize something and builds out
something terrific goes from
visualization to actualization of great
things
so um so people like um
bill gates and um uh
elon musk and um um
mark benioff um p diddy shawn combs
reed hastings all of those who
and many more jack dorsey and so on
those people
um have a demonstrated ability to go
from
um so i wanted to take their dna
intellectual dna so to speak
so i um gave them and a bunch more of
these profile tests assessment basically
that captures how they think
to get what that mix was for that kind
of a job
and of course it's valuable whatever job
the person is in but
that's what i did and i found that there
was a a pretty consistent profile
um includes uh eric yuan of uh
zoom and and others and there's a pretty
consistent profile
of that type of person in terms of uh
being able to do those things
point six percent of the population
roughly has that
so that was that group but i also
realized that i needed
not just that that these people
themselves needed
other qualities from other people
otherwise they wouldn't have gotten
anywhere
and so it was the ability to see how
they
then worked with others and um to
produce teams that taught me a lot and
that's what you're referring to
yeah i'm curious to hear more about the
shaper group point six percent of the
population
what are the qualities that they had in
common
um well so many but
um first um a sense of adventure and the
desire to have a giant
impact um they would simultaneously
um very very imaginative
um but a very very practical
would spend a lot of attention on that
really big
picture but let me give you an example
um uh elon musk
um when uh he let me
drive his car and and he gives me the
key
and he shows uh the details of how the
trunk
it works and all of that so to go
you know to mars and simultaneously pay
a lot of attention to that and the one
thing that was also very common of all
of those
is that there was no accepting of of
failure and the dealing with people uh
who were um the not accepting
uh less than excellence from people
being uh what i would say tough on
people now i gave
um mohammad yunus who
received the nobel peace prize for
inventing micro
finance and um having more
do good companies he's built more social
enterprise companies
than anybody he was also uh considered
one of the five
greatest entrepreneurs of our time by
fortune
i gave him the test i gave jeffrey
canada who changed
harlem children's zone uh to
he envisioned how to take care of
children in a hundred square blocks of
harlem
and they all care about people but all
of them
all of them would maintain those high
standards and work in a certain way
where they wouldn't
compromise the capabilities of
of people they would find their ways of
getting past that
so and i found that this is a big issue
in terms of achieving
those great goals how do you deal with
people's weaknesses
in order to achieve good so those are
some of the characteristics of of those
people
very humble very very humble interesting
um focused a lot of attention on what
they don't know these incredibly
successful people uh would be more
curious and more
enthusiastically taking in the best
thinking that they can
and you think okay well they're
brilliant and they're successful they're
successful because of what they know
they it's how they acquired what they
know through that voracious
appetite and the open-mindedness all of
those qualities they had in common
well one of the things that jumps out
for me there is that
these shapers are full of paradoxes
right these these traits that we think
are opposites actually seem to go hand
in hand in them right the
the seeing the big picture but also
focusing on the small details
the caring about the world but being
tough on individual people
uh i think that that combination is is
obviously powerful
now ray i'm i i'm intrigued by the fact
that we can see ourselves more clearly
through the principles you assessment
i i'm also struck by the fact that we
can see the people around us
more clearly and it can help us manage
all kinds of relationships
whether we're talking about our marriage
our friendships or our work teams and
we've we've worked together for a few
years now and i had a chance to look at
our results uh the juxtaposition of your
scores and mine on the assessment
and i was stunned that you were less
analytical than i am
what is going on there let me uh before
i answer that question i want to just
convey to the audience what what you're
saying
unlike a lot of tests which just give
you your results
these tests allow you test assessments
these allow you to bring in somebody
else and
they will describe your relationship
what you'll encounter in your
relationship with others
relationships uh with people you work
with
or relationships with as you say with
spouses friends and so on and they're
uncannily
accurate in being able to do that so
it's a big deal
um you know and and our um test it was
great because we both
uh worked together adam and i did on
building this and um
and as a as adam knows um
um like he asked the question he's more
analytical
than i am um and what you see in the
this profile is that i'm about
50 analytical and about 50
intuitive so what is coming to me is
i have a lot of intuitiveness so what it
balances when you look at that
is it says well what's your approach
what's your mix
so i'm more a mix of like 50 50
intuitive
and then analytical because i personally
believe
and i've experienced this that there's
the subconscious mind
that from the subconscious mind comes
wonderful ideas a lot of creativity
comes up that way
but that it has to be reconciled with
the analytical
mind in order to go ahead and use you
assume it's correct
so i'm about 50 50 where adam is very
much more
um um more the analytical
in terms of the evidence-based and we
see that in our relationship you know
we'll each push each other in in that
way
to get you know the best test well it
was it was eye-opening for me ray
because we've we've had these moments
where
i want to change your mind and i bring
you some evidence and you say i don't
care about the evidence because it
doesn't match my intuition and it
it led me to think that we can
collaborate more effectively by me
asking you
ray tell me more about where that
intuition intuition came from and
can we unpack it together yeah this is a
very big thing for me
when i align evidence and logic
they have to align so when you bring to
me
something that's evidence and we then
say okay well
that's good that's a good challenge
because it better align but then you
have to align those two things so that's
you know that's that's how you see it
the the interactions i think
well i i love that as an example of of
how seeing yourself more clearly and
seeing the people around you more
clearly can
help resolve conflicts or help you have
more productive conflicts
so good because like us when we work
together
we understood that through the tests and
then we operated with that
and you know there are um these are
valuable
uh a daughter of a a law of mine at a
dinner
uh gave me uh the test of our family we
had all of our family together and she
gave us uh the personality uh profile
uh for five types of love i don't know
if you've ever heard of that but that's
one of those
in terms of the different types of love
and we took it and we understood and we
understood each other better and helped
us so much
so there are many ways of uh of doing
that it depends what you're trying to
get at
well i think one of the things that
people often worry about when they take
an assessment like this
is could i fail am i going to find out
that i have a bad personality right
how do you how do you think through that
there's no failure
this is just like your thinking
preferences
right um nature
nature did invented everything for a
purpose
so nature has given us different ways of
thinking
everything has a purpose and so um when
you look at it
objectively and you say is that me
and um and then if you if it doesn't
ring true
by but almost always it rings very true
but if it doesn't or
doesn't ring true then it raises a
question to look at
so that you can then examine that and
find out from others
is that me or uh whatever and then when
you know
yourself you know like um you know know
thyself uh and then when you know
yourself you can
move beyond so it's not it's not a test
it's any more than if you would ask you
do you prefer uh steak or lobster or
vanilla or chocolate
one of the things i i find amusing when
people go through an assessment like
principles you
is they'll come out and say you know i i
think there are a couple things in here
that are really wrong about me
i'm like you you answered the questions
it's your fault if you don't like the
answers go take it again
and uh but it is so good to reconcile
and i've seen its impact on
relationships
personal development and relationships
and and you know we're talking a lot
about it
but it's just kind of simple it takes
you somewhere it's free
takes you somewhere between a half an
hour and 40 minutes or something to do
it's fun to do so you know go
do it and if and see what it's like
and then if you like it you can pass it
along to other people
and you could say hey this i think
there's a good description of me or you
can
ask somebody to take theirs and see how
you match up
i mean what what can go wrong we're
talking about it
just you know taste it see what it's
like
i i think there's a lot that can be
learned through going through the
assessment and
of course that's only the beginning
right you have a whole suite of tools
that are coming out
talk to us a little bit about how
principles u integrates with the dot
collector
well again i found it
terrifically powerful to know what
people
are like um and how they interact and
what they think
i'm above all else i wanted to have an
idea meritocracy in which the goals are
meaningful work and meaningful
relationships through radical
truthfulness and radical transparency
so allowing people to express themselves
collect data look at everything in a
database way
with them as partners and so one of the
tools
i created was a dot collector which
allows all of those things
uh to happen it's quite often in
meetings um
but it's um it's a tool that allows
people to
express their thoughts and collect the
data and and do that
and so when it's connected with um the
principles you uh it has the the
uh consistency is that picture coming
back
is the facts that i'm um
seeing do they align with what
my actions do they align with what i'm
like in terms of the profile
and it helps to foster that
kind of development personal
understanding and development
i i think it's incredibly enlightening
to be able to hold up that mirror right
and say how do other people perceive me
and am i
actually expressing my personality the
way that i think i am
and sometimes i'm not and it's a
discovery process
there's no definitive truths it's always
whether the individual when they're in
they say does that make sense
how do you reconcile it nobody's
imposing this on it or have a definitive
it's like if it's not does it line up
okay what do you figure
how do you figure how do you learn and
what explains the differences
and it's that kind of evolution that has
had
it's been you know a key to the success
i've
started bridgewater 46 years ago and um
and knowing what people are like and how
they work well
is key to meaningful work and meaningful
relationships
well i think having principles you to
assess yourself
and then the dot collector to get
feedback from others it
feels a little bit to me like what i
miss from being an athlete which is
there's there's a coach there
every single moment telling me how i
could get better
uh ray one of the the challenges that a
lot of people face is then acting on
that information if you were just gonna
close with one tip
about about how to take the feedback and
use it effectively what would you share
uh that knowing what you don't know
and knowing what your weaknesses
are is the most powerful way
to achieving great success it's the
opposite of what you're taught
in most cases people are thinking i have
to be great and it's all
in my head and nobody
is has been fabulously successful that
way
because nobody has it all
well that's a great place to land ray
fun to chat with you as always now let's
go back to collision in toronto
thank you and thank you for your help
thank you